So when we have a vector
product of two vectors,
A cross B equals C, let's
compute that vector product
in different coordinate systems.
So let's begin by
choosing two vectors.
I hat, and J hat.
And notice they're
at a right angle,
and because there
is a unit vector,
the area here is equal to and 1.
And I want to define K hat to
be equal to I hat cross J hat.
Now, our angle theta
here was 90 degrees.
And so, if I use the right
hand rule, then I hat,
cross J hat is-- the right
handed unit normal is out
of the plane of the figure.
And so I would write
K hat like that,
and notice K hat is
out of plane of figure.
And because I used
my right hand rule,
this is what we call a right
handed coordinate system.
Now, there's something very
nice about this cross product
definition.
Notice that there's
a cyclic order.
IJK is a cyclic order.
And if you interchange any two.
For example, JIK,
that's anti-cyclic.
And the cross products satisfy
this cyclic rule, in that,
J cross K hat is I hat.
And notice JKI, maintains
that cyclic order, and K hat
cross I hat is J hat.
KIJ maintains that cyclic
order, but because of the way
we defined a cross-product
in general A cross B
is minus B cross A,
because now you're
using the opposite direction,
so there's a minus sign.
And therefore, any anti-cyclic
permutation of these unit
vectors, as an example, K
hat cross J hat, has to be--
notice I've-- is minus I
hat-- that's anti-communitive
property of the cross-product.
Similarly, I hat cross
K hat is minus J hat.
And lastly, J hat cross
I hat is minus K hat.
And so, in fact, you
only need to know one.
And this idea of
cyclic, and anti-cyclic,
to be able to write
down all of the other 6.
So we have one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Now, when you want to
compute the cross products
in Cartesian coordinates,
for instance,
it can be a little bit messy.
There's going to
be a lot of terms.
If I write a vector
A as A X I hat
plus A Y J hat plus A Z K hat.
And I write a vector B as BX
I hat plus BY J hat plus BZ K
hat.
And now I want to compute the
cross-product of these vectors
to get the new one.
Notice that there's going
to be six terms, because I
have I hat-- well, we actually
should say one more thing.
that I hat cross I hat-- the
angle between these two vectors
is zero.
There's no perpendicular
projection.
So that's zero, as is J hat
cross J hat, K hat cross K hat.
So of these nine parts, when
we take the cross-product,
three of them will
be 0, by this rule,
and we'll we apply our
cyclic or anti-cyclic rules
for the others.
And so what we have
here-- let's just do it
in-- so C equals A cross B.
And now let's just
go one by one.
I hat cross I hat.
That's 0.
There's no perpendicular part.
The area formed by
these two vectors is 0.
I hat cross J hat.
That's cyclic.
IJ is plus K hat.
So our first non-zero term is
AXBY K hat I hat cross J hat.
And now let's do
I hat cross K hat.
Notice that's anti-cyclic.
I K minus J. So our next
term is minus AX BZ J hat.
So there's the first two.
And now let's just
continue this process.
J hat cross I hat.
That's anti-cyclic.
So we have minus AY BX K hat.
AY J hat across BX I hat.
J hat cross J hat.
That's 0.
So we have no
contribution there.
And J hat crossed K
hat, that is cyclic.
So that's plus AY BZ K hat.
And now we have our last
two terms K hat cross I hat.
That cyclic.
So that's plus AZ BX J hat.
K hat cross J hat.
That's anti-cyclic.
So there's a minus I hat.
So it's minus AZ BY I hat.
And finally K hat cross K
hat, well that's also 0.
So we have six terms.
And we can collect them
equal to AX BY minus-- well
let's check this one.
Here we used the
wrong symbol here.
We have to be a little
bit careful here.
AY cross BZ is J
hat cross K hat.
That's plus I hat.
So we have AXBY
minus AY BX K hat.
And now let's look
at the I hat terms.
I'll just check those off.
We have AY BZ minus AZ BY I hat.
And check those two terms off.
And lastly, we have
AZ BX minus AXPZ.
So we have AZBX minus
AX BZ and that's J hat.
And that's how we
calculate the cross-product
in Cartesian coordinates.